um I think all pickup lines are the
worst I really don't think they work you
know if you just come up to me and
you're nice and you make me laugh seems
like you're having a good time you'll
catch my attention that way yes I work
out three times a week with a personal
trainer and then I try and do cardio
twice a week depends how lazy I am I
grew up in a family that really loves
sports they're are sports fanatics and
we were always going to games and my
sister works for the New York Jets so
I'm a big jets fan and I also enjoy
going to Yankee games if I wasn't
modeling I would still be Shing horses
and probably going to college I can cook
but I don't know if I'm very good like I
try to cook very healthy so it ends up
being super plain best place I ever
traveled was the Philippines for Sports
Illustrated it was so far away and you
know when you land it was a 40-hour
travel time so you're like I'm not going
to enjoy this I'm just going to be
grumpy but it was so beautiful you know
it's really hard to be jet lagged and
have to go early call times and still
look sharp but um and then again you get
to travel around the world so it's the
best part
[Music]
twoo